welcome to this video come on TR know
that really the name no idea God
probably this the name ok No Quintillian
oh I'm sorry one win one loss so and
play them before ok gets a bit a bit
like them like a hedgehog this position
for black and night is on c6 so ever
interesting night to h5 mmm do I want to
move that sometimes III is an idea and
let's do that getting this this funky
pawn structure maybe he just goes back
which is six interesting I don't mind
him taking
okay then I have to give my bishop some
some kind of squares so you form I mean
we can go 95 and I don't see the big
idea so this was really intentional
maybe it was might be five en and a six
c5 may be very weird never seen that og
black gives away d 6 495 in a similar
structure but maybe this is liable
I Teague b6 don't quite get it okay I'm
taking may be overlooked 27 okay if I
take b6 is possibly nights if for God
Bishop a six
9c for Quincy 5 92 95 something like
that maybe 93 is on though okay hmm
that's that's not good
hmm 93 when it's only saw that now if i
go back to e3 scott rook a3 and possible
book d three moves huh it's tough to
cover that t3 square and you just back
here looks a bit strange maybe it's okay
I'm just covering the a porn I still can
go back to e3 here after 93
QC one is not playable back here then
Casey three of the tech guys got pretty
active play here voice for his pawn my
pieces don't call you need well nights
especially as we know they need our
posts and nights you for Who am I going
actually to g5 yeah I don't have any
square sir I have to go here
should be seven don't know is that doing
anything probably not much but played it
quickly
I Quincy three or so maybe hi Quincy 3m
not very well coordinated night moves
Quincy two or so hmm Quincy three or
this one
I can check with the Queen on your phone
I don't have 91 okay hmm I got sooo back
to play for that porn
yeah maybe objectively I was okay or
even better I don't know but practing a
practical game that was pretty awful to
play check
I'm happy to have traded some stuff at
least still not coordinated well okay
true or something
time warning doesn't look right Quincy
to wear Quincy to I can take b7 okay all
right let's let's get out of this okay
so that that should be should be equal
now it gave me that pawn for no
particular reason check let's check I'm
sure maybe have some chances here with
the activity I probably you can check me
here shall hold on check
check check check look afraid i'd still
a draw of course check check I had this
one ok check what its places on time or
bloody bloody [ __ ] check check check
check check check they should have
avoided the draw he's even slow this guy
unbelievable stuff marry again so ji was
an interesting game it was an
interesting game at 97 idea i've never
seen ever etiquette hat it's also hard
to believe but so ok when i went to see
5 and the engine just wants to go back
but this I couldn't really believe ok I
didn't didn't think of this one but you
know it be 5 might be on on 96 and why
it seems better than c5 I had 93 him
yeah blackest black is very active her I
mean this is a shouldn't work ready
button and he got got lots of active
play and I Quincy eight why didn't I do
that by the way and why does just better
hmm i have night a for him I although
that was the way to do it now I didn't
think about this man ya hear this 93
idea gives him lots of play I hear lagi
for was winning for black man that's it
and I'm so badly coordinated that it's
no big surprise check and yeah but you
didn't get anywhere and now 95 force
winning Quincy to but also winning yeah
well he played this one windy send any
blunder t5 and then try to win on time
with with rook against Rome great stuff
and I wonder if there are some chances
here in this position probably have to
do it differently check this this and
some look g8 maybe if I go here let's go
just got the check so probably have to
start with this soup here and somewhere
like that and then we'll create this
might give me some winning chances check
there
and the engine gives why the total win
but I'm always a bit skeptical down like
this now that should win yeah it should
really will go here and then push
therefore okay it is really a win
sometimes you have to be a bit skeptical
about the engines because they are not I
mean the engine here doesn't have table
base so some some positions it might
just simply miss evaluate seen enough of
those so I really want to make up my own
mind a little bit there okay well thanks
for watching